In this problem for Unit 5, I want you to implement the control algorithm that you saw
in sections 2 and 15 of Unit 5 for the hydraulic braking system.
We've set up a number of important values for you, as always,
including two things called low slip and high slip.
These are both possible values for the real slip.
If the real slip gets smaller than low slip, we want you to decrease the pressure of the brakes.
Similarly, if the real slip gets higher than high slip, we wan you to increase the pressure.
Increasing and decreasing the pressure like this leads to rate of change called hydraulic speed
in the strength p of the brake.
Hydraulic speed is shown right here while p the braking strength which you can see right here
is measured as the deceleration of the velocity at the rim of the wheel
if there is no friction from the road.
Possibly logical, the strength of the brake cannot be a negative number
and we've set the maximum value that it can take on with this constant called max brake right here.
You're going to need most of the contents of the for loop inside this function,
but there are a couple of line left that we want you to write.
We want you to model how the brake pressure changes between these maximum and minimum
values that we outlined above, and using these, how the brake acceleration changes step by step.
This might require a little bit of creativity, so if you need some hints, come to the forums.